latina women my 11 month old latina
daughter has can't walk yeah can dance
better than me i've seen it she can
dance better than me i've seen it in my
latino nieces they're better than us
they're just like they already have a
built-in thing now i will say i not i
don't do it much now but i am half a
latino
and thus i've been dancing my whole life
now there are times where i have to get
on the dance floor and leave it all out
there you have to i have to and i do i
leave it all
you're not going to leave it all out
there are you doing
fifty percent of the time i'm out there
i leave it there hundred percent
hundred percent at fifty percent it's
left you have to go back and get it you
forgot it yeah the other fifty percent i
still contribute but i maybe not don't
leave it all out there
in your body and your heart your soul
and your mind when you're hearing
something and your brain's going nuts
and you wish you could leave it all out
there
and you don't what happens how does that
make you feel
because you can't just walk around your
whole life not leaving it out there
i feel like a failure